il est temps d'accueillir celui qui est
avec nous ce soir on va faire une heure
tout droit avec les cheveux il y en a
plein de surprises et après reste avec
nous il va réagir surtout cab adams est
avec nous applaudissements pour les
cadres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
alors on s'est dit et les
téléspectateurs au revoir il ya bien sûr
des huit heures sur sur twitter
notamment est le premier acteur qui tu
as écrit c max 55,90 5590 on regarde le
tweet et tu peux lui répondre tu vas
lire le tweet est lui répond alors voilà
je viens d'en alors je les dis le nom du
gars donc voila merci bien de regarder
14 minutes du pire film de l'histoire à
la deux tristes écriture aucun intérêt
nul vraiment cave adams nullissime
que lui répondez coûte c'est dommage
parce qu'à partir de la 15e minute 7
c'est le meilleur tireur il a regardé
plus tu vas pas le voit dans le film
alors le deuxième éditeur
c'est une personne que tu as bloqué sur
twitter qui a écrit ça regarde c'est
parti non maintenant le deuxième c'est
le corbeau alors le corbeau ont bloqué
les ondes bloquant les twittos ce qu'ils
lui disent qu'il est pas drôle ah non
non non non je vais pas bloquée puisque
il dit qu' que je suis pas drôle a le
droit de le penser je les bloquerai
puisqu'on ne comprends pas ce que dit
cette personne
non là c'est le festival du prononcé un
génie en bloquant les twittos ski frère
le frérot le corbeau su nous regardent
et crie pas les tweets acte est plus mon
frère andy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous les films de cas madame sont nuls
tous les films de cannes aime son nul
puisque je vais te répondre à ça la
seule chose qui me vient c'est tu les a
tous vus c'est beaucoup quoi sert il en
a vu un premier cic nul je regarde celui
d'après après c'est nul ça c'est le
genre de gars il mange un truc il dit
c'est dégueulasse
heureusement un peu quand j'ai envie de
regoûter combattants petit film et
jacques est maintenant jusqu'à
maintenant 12 avril a vu les 12 il a vu
les deux merci à lui d'avoir vu les 12,6
et faire voir et mis son jugement ici
c'est un kiff le 4ème éditeur et un
auteur qui n'aiment pas les humoristes
mais qui aime la bagarre et qui dit
regarde caisse 10 et 10,5 à madame anne
roumanoff l'autre lakamy lellouche dans
un autre style eux j'ai envie de me
battre avec eux mdr bah ça va faire une
baston très chaud louanges une bascule
très étrange regarde le cinquième
attendez fous rires ma soeur elle a une
veste car madame je lui fais quoi
dis lui que je passe la récupérer c'est
moi je l'oublié la semaine dernière oh
non mais on m'a alors dit encore radio
on aime bien j'aime bien cette séquence
à [ __ ] ce qu'elle aime soit on
réveille toute assez chaud le mec se
réveille la tronche du canada à c'est
très drôle
ouais vous reconnaitre cette fois ils
sont méchants gratuitement autant là
c'est très drôle très bon
[Applaudissements]
hier magasin derrière vous avez frais de
leur laisser arriver ici c'est quoi
c'est quoi ce nouveau dos alors ça oui
pas question à la tête de ma mère a way
et c'est qui c'est un bal à la faute et
ne sais pas il faut deviner
ah non mais c'est pas du tout cette
séquence là parce que là on est sur le
rideau à bloc là bas et après on va
venir ici tu dois dominique est ça qui
est là c'est ça le gros contre sa
hauteur alors ouais ouais c'est ma mère
excusez moi il ya que des lecteurs ce
sera sérieux oui qatar qia show tateurs
tâche aux chartrains dessus et du culte
a pas aidé car on va faire un tour héros
d'un jour je suis bien d'accord mac en
attendant ternes allemand doit pas
devinez qui c'est là derrière et tout ça
si c'est ça cette émission est
complètement désordonnée armes et auteur
c'est plus tard à temps et les frères ça
le devient encore l'instant c'est le
rideau à bluff se cache derrière le
rideau
elle a atteint la phase a battu va venir
me voir puisque vous allez essayer de
trouver il ya des surprises pour toi kev
jouer avec toi bien sûr tu es avec moi
ni avec moi ni avec moi on va jouer un
jeu vous connaissez tous evry doivent
des choses se cacher derrière le rideau
vous allez voter qui dit la vérité quel
vin ou moi d'accord à tokyo
kev regarde regarde moi ce qu'elle
regarde regarde discrètement je
regarderai vous êtes des malades plus ya
alors il là il ya ya passe partout voilà
deux ans voyant ouais mais en rabbin
genre passe par touches quoi tu vois
quand est ce que t'as vu c'est ce que
j'ai vu
[Rires]
non en fait derrière il ya le père
fouras avec un manteau de fourrure c'est
le père fourreur le père fourreur le
père fourreur est ce que j'avance avec
yb l'office et passe pas je peux soit le
père fourreur est ce que c'est parce
partout où est-ce que donc vous dites qu
elle bluffe cadeau qu'est la syrie
leboeuf cyril blog cyril joseph cyril
boeuf on va voir tout de suite faire
fourrer avez raison c'est pas comprise
par tous en rabbin sa voix est normal
[Rires]
que la ville n'avait pas vu leur pass
partout à rabat
[Rires]
roger damour
[Musique]
andré c'est un pote depuis très très
longtemps
andré g le kid on sait qu'on va ta femme
va bien j'aurai célèbre bar est la 11e
deuxième candidat doivent caire hier
deux il y en a un deuxième temps diana
de salut bonjour je vais regarder ça
bien des toits salom
[Rires]
c'est énorme
alors là je vous le dis c'est quoi là je
vais même pas de faire regarder ah ouais
non plus énorme que ce passe parfois au
rabbin que tu vas juste vous dire bien
là tu vas venir la rochelle tu vas juste
veut dire si c'est vrai ou si c'est faux
vas-y d'accord derrière la chute yoplait
arthur merci tueries nous font toujours
chier sur les chéris derrière ce rideau
je comptais de mémoire de kevin à bluff
non là sinon il y as tes deux papas 1-2
papin quand je lis tes deux papas ya ton
vrai papa est ton papa de soda guinée
qu'on a rien ou font peu ou pas je pense
est vrai ton vrai papa et guy trois
contrats ils se connaissent ils sont vus
déjà des deux papas ça me paraît très
moins probable que passe partout en
ravanche et français tu penses vraiment
que ton père pour faire revenir son
plateau ouais mon père il peut venir ou
pas pour revenir on perd et vient
tranquille je code bassin bah écoute
[Applaudissements]
cela
mon coeur on a quelqu'un qui est
derrière
derrière center voilà je te le dis c'est
quelqu'un qui ne t'aime pas d'accord tu
vas pouvoir lui poser des questions
tu as une minute pour trouver cette
personne
au caire quelque chose à te dire nati
elle va te répondre à chaque fois il se
pose des questions c'est ça il faut
qu'ils posent des questions ok travers
de henry j s'il vous plaît en régie
c'est bon tout est calé c'est parti
vas-y une minute comment vous
appelez-vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis dit ça alors ce que tu peux
demander est ce que est ce que vous êtes
un homme ou une femme je pense connaître
la réponse
alors alors alors c'est lui qui pose les
questions du coup je pense vous êtes une
femme oui très bien vous ne vous ne
m'aimez vous ne m'aimez pas non d'accord
de quelle façon vous êtes matthieu
delormeau
non est ce que vous me connaissez
personnellement oui à une ex une ex
avait non pas je pense pas vous êtes une
ex à moi mais allez vous avez 15
secondes pour trouver vous auriez vous
auriez pu être une ex à moi non vous
vous ne m'aimez pas pour quelle raison
vous avez une raison précise
vous vous êtes humour oui beta c'est
trop pour 15 secondes syrie ces jeux si
je vous dis
la personne qui est derrière le rideau
oui elle s'appelle bérénice béret me
nomme bérénice et paille terre vernissée
mais c'est ma première fois c'est ma
prof de théâtre quand j'étais petit quoi
elle mal maël map
elle m'a appris le théâtre en fête va se
dire c'est pas du tout acteur puisque ta
première prof de théâtre est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez vu en cour à quel âge
bérénice 13 ans 13 ans il était il était
bon déjà ou pas en impro et était très
bon vous saviez que ça allait devenir
une énorme star comme ça on parle de
femmes est lui surtout il le savait lui
wen a pas ce que je fais mais on aurait
plus pêchu je crois quand même un an
elle est allée très jolie en tout cas et
puis elle est très douée elle a un
atelier qui s'appelle la teulière le cas
on en profite pour en parler sur qui
forment plein plein plein de d'enfants
et plein d'ados est assez génial
puisqu'elle tu apprends le théâtre mais
elle s'adapte aussi un peu toi moi par
exemple tu vois les exercices et tout
moi j'avais envie de tout le temps faire
plein de trucs
et ben moi c'était difficile pour l
algérie au milieu de tout un groupe mais
jamais elle te dit tu fais pas ci fais
pas ça lequel tu encourage à aller vers
le meilleur de toi même
on a besoin de gens comme si tout ce
qu'il fait ou pas mais tout ce qui fait
ses films si c'était vous allez voir son
spectacle soit disant eh ben je vous
mets deux places et pour moi nous avons
appris que julien bravo
bah merci chez hyper fier du parcours
d'avoir de t'avoir rencontré à 13 ans et
que c'est vraiment chouette de devoir
cette fidélité que tu as toujours pour
cette école puisque à chaque événement
que l'on peut organiser
on sait que malgré mon peu du temps
hyper chargé on peut compter sur toi et
c'est précieux donc merci il ya
quelqu'un qui a voulu me faire un défi
il voulait faire le défi ping pong les
abords des chemins
je vous le dis si qu'elle gagne alors
c'est caire car chetrat des places pour
son spectacle pour tout public
d'accord d'accord c'est exact si c'est
moi non non non non non tu viens de te
retrouver cyril pardonne c'est vrai
c'est super je perds si tu perds je la
vis tout le monde exactement et surpris
tout le monde à mon spectacle où tu veux
d'ailleurs d'accord bien vite d'accord
et si je perds j'invite tout le monde à
mons et moi c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
alors on fait ça en cinq points en cinq
points ça me va cinq points juste
excusez moi j'aimerai savoir parmi les
chroniqueurs
parmi tous vous êtes pour qui l'image
ragga taille et hugo parents c'est pas
bon avez-vous évidemment il anime
merci je peux dire attends que gynéco de
se taire merci merci donc ça maddox qui
justement un petit lui parler dire et
c'est dieu
la cgc pour ksm bravo merci gilles a
toujours constructives paye mon coeur
mais vous agissez pour vous mais
pourquoi
mais bon c'est pour vous ça fait dix ans
j'ai pas joué un joli on peut dire que
je suis là outsiders comme on irait tout
bas on y va direct un bon style mais tu
vois ça atteint c'est à zéro on peut
mettre les pieds aux personnes il ya
isabelle morini-bosc ont dit non mais la
table et pas homologuer la série
[Musique]
combien de points 23 maillot au [ __ ]
c'est pas jouer ses cheveux c'est pas
d'étape ça c'est pas les tableaux dire
je te jure que s'ils savaient combien de
zéros alors on croise ok moi ça fait
plaisir
3 c'est pas fini les patins pascal n'est
pas finie sur mac ward
vous voyez
aulas allait pas mal
allez allez va allez allez allez
non 4 en battant trois balles de match
ça sent pas bon ça sent clairement pas
bon c'est parti a besoin quand je disais
j'habite tout le monde c'est de la
lettre à aa la lettre à m
[Applaudissements]
ça